Chances are you know someone suffering
from back or neck pain—two-thirds of adults suffer
from some level of back or neck pain
at some point in their lives
One of the most common causes of back and neck pain
is degeneration of the discs -
the shock absorbers that act as padding
between each link in the spine.
The typical surgical treatments for a degenerated disc
are expensive, painful and can actually
cause other nearby discs to breakdown over time.
Now a team of researchers have developed a new
technique to grow engineered discs in the lab.
First, they seeded a disc made of a hydrogel polymer
with stem cells taken from a goat.
The seeded disc was then sandwiched
between two pieces of foam made from
a polymer called polycaprolactone.
The researchers implanted the lab-grown discs
into the necks of goats.
The discs were subjected to
periodic compression tests
to compare their performance to natural ones.
Researchers found that after 8 weeks,
the engineered discs ability to withstand compression
became just as good as the natural discs.
All of the goats recovered from the implantation surgery
without complication and possessed full
range of motion in their necks
throughout the study duration.
We are, unfortunately, a long way off from human trials
researchers would like to continue long-term studies
of the effectiveness of the discs in goats
and other larger mammals.
Still, this could mean that in the future,
those with end-stage disc degeneration
would be able to turn to discs grown in a lab
to ease their suffering.